the marvel cinematic universe needs
doctor doom
and here's the reason why and yes i know
my hairline's crooked it's been crooked
since i was like seven i don't care so
here's the thing uh the marvel cinematic
universe villains and this is a point
that we will reiterate over the course
of these videos right because i feel
like it just cannot be said enough
the marvel cinematic universe villains
are formulaic right you can set your
watch to an mcu villain they're very
very very two-dimensional if you if you
look at thanos objectively right remove
the whole idea of like the lines and the
really really cool fight scenes in the
moments
look at thanos objectively
what is thanos thanos is a guy whose
world basically died because of
overpopulation and they're not being
enough resources and so for reasons that
really only ever makes sense to himself
he decided that half the universe needs
to be blinked out of existence because
there's too many people and not enough
resources how he knows that i don't
really know i have a hard time believing
thanos traveled to every single planet
and studied every single planet's
geopolitical landscape across the entire
universe and came to that conclusion
maybe he did right whatever the case
happens to be thanos was two dimensional
in that way it's a very very boring and
very very basic motivation for a villain
who in the comics is far more dynamic
and usually way more interesting but
even as intriguing as thanos is in the
comics
doctor doom's just that much better dr
doom is a very dynamic and very
intriguing and very motivating
and sometimes hilarious villain
he's one of these guys where he could
bring a
element to the marvel cinematic universe
that it simply just lacks and that's
creating a villain that not only is
doing villainous things but that you
actually kind of find yourself rooting
for right because when it comes to
doctor doom i mean it's just it's it's
just
he's great and almost everywhere okay so
let's use examples here to give you guys
a well-rounded depiction of doctor doom
right to give you guys an understanding
of who he is as a villain and then we'll
talk about how this could benefit the
marvel cinematic universe so let's talk
about his cockiness right doctor doom is
arrogant just extremely arrogant like
you guys think loki is arrogant no
doctor doom is on a whole different
level of arrogance one he only ever
refers to himself in the third person
doctor doom does not refer to himself as
i or me or anything like that so imagine
if like over the course of the marvel
cinematic universe loki always referred
to himself in the third person and
that's basically doom right like it's
just it's it's it's crazy so another
really good example of his arrogance is
during jonathan hickman's avengers and
new avengers right it's one of the best
comment like the best comic book story
ever written but there's a point where
basically neymar the submariner goes to
visit doctor doom and the reason why is
of course the multiverse is collapsing
earth are crashing into each other which
destroys their respective universes and
so when the illuminati initially learned
about it name of the submariner and reed
richards and iron man and doctor strange
and all those guys basically came
together and because the infinity
gauntlet worked but was destroyed at the
same time there was no discernible means
to stop an incursion unless they were to
obliterate the other earth uh the
illuminati didn't want to do that they
were not okay with wiping out an entire
planet to save their own name of the
submariner was and so he ultimately
defected and then joined thanos and his
coal obsidian right so like corvus
glaive and supergiant proxima midnight
and all those guys the problem was
neymar didn't know what he was getting
into and thanos and his guys it wasn't
simply enough to destroy that world to
basically prevent the destruction of the
main marvel universe they would actually
relish it they became bloodlusted right
they would kill all the superheroes on
that world and so neymar realizing just
how badly he screwed up realized thanos
and those guys had to be stuck so then
he goes to see dr doom there's this
amazing exchange that takes place
between the two of them i just this
amazing exchange
where where dr doom is talking about the
people of latvia right the people that
he basically rules over as their
dictator slash benevolent leader if
there is such a thing and what he says
to namor is he says do you really
believe that if these people wanted to
kill me or oust me as their leader that
they couldn't do it
they could anytime they wanted to they
could kill me they could destroy me they
could push me out right they could force
me out of liberia because i would rather
leave than see harm come to them he says
but i keep them protected i keep them
watered i'd keep them fed i keep them
safe so before they pray to whatever god
they pray to you when they go to sleep
they give thanks to me it's like the
most arrogant [ __ ] ever right so then
like neymar finally asked him like are
you going to help me destroy thanos and
they call obsidian and dr doom's like no
i'm not going to he's like it's bad
enough you threw in your lot with like
reed richards and all those guys because
dr doom hates reid he was like but then
after that went south you went to ally
yourself with thanos with a mad titan
and then you come to me when that goes
wrong right you bring the stinking
carcass of your failure to my front door
he was like you should know by now namor
dr doom is no one's second choice
literally he refused to help neymar the
submariner for no other reason than the
fact that neymar didn't come to him
first right it's petty it's like the
most petty thing ever but it's hilarious
right it's hilarious in that way right
imagine that kind of scenario being
transferred to the marvel cinematic
universe now the other part of this and
this is where like the villainous aspect
of doctor doom really comes into play
his his quest for power is insatiable it
can never be quelled right he can never
have enough power for any number of
reasons way back in the day it was due
to the fact that his mother's soul was
taken by mephisto when she had made a
deal with mephisto in order to basically
learn witchcraft and the story triumph
and torment doctor strange and doctor
doom freed his mother's soul so she was
basically allowed to go to heaven ever
since then the whole acquisition of just
huge amounts of power has largely just
been dr doom being a dick that's really
all it is right just just him just being
a bad guy but it's still cool right it's
one of those cool things this was
solidified and jonathan hickman's
fantastic four when you had what was
called the council of reeds basically
this coming together of all these
different iterations of reed richards
from across the multiverse pretty much
all of whom had abandoned their own
families for the quest of solving the
the problem of everything right fixing
all these different multiversal problems
and so what this did is it led to this
realization that in in multiple
universes not every universe but in
multiple universes dr doom will rise to
power and then he'll basically try to
just consolidate as much power as he
possibly can whenever this happens in an
alternate reality they would basically
kidnap that version of doctor doom then
they would lobotomize him and they would
stick him in a basement below the
citadel where the council resided like
literally there were just dozens of
these doctor dooms and they just sat
down there i am doomed i am doomed
that's all they did but it solidified
that doctor doom's quest for power can
never ever be satiated and it makes
sense because in the comics dr dumas had
the power cosmic so basically he's had
the power of galactus he had the power
of the beyonder and the beyonder himself
was more powerful than god at his peak
he's had cosmic cubes he's had the
infinity gauntlet he's had all these
things over the course of his entire
existence and yet it's still never
enough power now sit that on the back
burner for a second because we'll talk
about that and we'll come back to that
here in a little bit but the other part
of this and what really really makes dr
doom so dynamic is that for all the pomp
and circumstance and all the arrogance
and all the hubris and all that kind of
stuff he's kind of a softy at his core
to a degree he respects intelligence as
much as he hates reed richards he
respects him because of how intelligent
he is and in fact he even respects
valeria richards the daughter of reed
who arguably is as smart if not smarter
than both reed and victor von doom
marvel kind of toys with it and a lot of
the times they say she's more
intelligent than they are because she's
more imaginative because she's a child
whereas they're adults so their
imagination has largely been removed
from the equation they stick more to
like logic and reason different things
along those lines but he respects
intelligence when it comes to the people
of liberia he's very similar to black
panther right black panther would burn
the world before he ever allowed
anything to happen to the people in
wakanda like literally he would seize
control of the world's nuclear arsenal
and just wipe out the rest of the world
in a nuclear holocaust if he had to
choose between them or wakanda that's
just the way that it is dr dooms the
exact same way woe be tied the poor soul
who goes into latviria and starts
causing problems especially if doctor
dooms around there to see it because he
will end them with a quickness there's
no arguing that point right there's no
debating that dr doom cares
just profusely about his people right he
treats them like like like they're his
children right he cares about them in
the same way that a parent loves a child
he would never let any harm come to the
latvians no matter the circumstance in
that caring nature it provides the human
dynamic so you take all those things and
you roll them all up together and then
you throw them in the mcu and what you
get is a villain unlike any that you've
seen before in the marvel cinematic
universe you get a guy who is wildly
complex you realize he's a bad guy you
realize he does bad things but you
realize that it's also because it's just
the nature of his inner torment it's the
nature of him the things he's gone
through the things he's struggled with
that just you know kind of give him that
motivation and desire that he has his
quest for power if they choose to keep
this intact is all for the purpose of
being able to basically defeat mephisto
and get his mother's soul back if they
end up deciding to go to the the ladder
of doctor doom just basically being a
dick i'm okay with that too that's
perfectly fine right but this guy could
be a villain and he could be a hero he
can bounce back and forth between the
two it's one of those things like i mean
like for all the the the villainous
things he did and where he seemed like
he was a straight-up bad guy and
jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers he was the first one to figure
out what was happening with the
incursions right and well really he was
also the one who caused it but that's
beside the point the important thing
here is that he figured out what was
going on he was doing everything he
could to save the multiverse while at
the same time not really sharing any of
his information with anybody else he's
hugely and immensely intelligent right
just wildly capable you add that just
dynamic right that the nature of a
villain like that who is hugely
intelligent way beyond what tony stark
is i mean way beyond what tony stark is
the funny thing is that if tony stark
had like gone to dr doom in like
avengers in game and was like victor von
doom like i have discovered time travel
the first thing doom would do is analyze
his research the thing the second thing
he would do is he would say this is
sloppy that's exactly what dr doom would
do right he would just be like this is
this is sloppy stark i expected better
of a man of your talent right and then
he would clean up tony stark's work and
then he would give it back to him that's
what dr doom would have done right
that's that's just how capable this guy
is either that or he would have stolen
it because doctor doom has a means of
time travel he's got a time platform so
he has the ability to travel back and
forth through time guy can do virtually
anything the stuff that tony stark
figures out doctor doom's known for a
long long time and just simply hasn't
implemented it because he doesn't want
to or because whatever whatever reason
it wouldn't benefit him in some way but
whatever the case is you take him and
you throw him into the marvel cinematic
universe and you've basically got a
person who is light years ahead of tony
stark in terms of intelligence and is
seemingly light years ahead of anybody
else in terms of their ability to
navigate a situation
to understand how to cope with huge
levels of power i mean the guy's just
the guy's he's in a league on his own
he's in his his very own league now
having said that
can you make doctor doom work by himself
and that's where things get a little
hairy if we were talking about the
storyline the books of doom which is the
most comprehensive origin of dr doom
which i won't spoil the ending in case
you guys decide to go read it sure right
you could do a dr doom solo film in the
vein of the books of doom right one of
the best doctor doom stories ever
written if what we're doing is throwing
doctor doom into the marvel cinematic
universe he does best when you're
bouncing him off of other people dr doom
is the most entertaining when he's
interacting with other people otherwise
it's just him sitting in his castle just
being a dick to his doombots right just
you know and talking down to the people
around him when you have him in the
presence of reed richards and it's the
bickering back and forth between him and
reid or if he's analyzing the research
of somebody out there or something along
those lines those kinds of things make
him cool when you have a story like do
more where doctor doom invades wakanda
and then takes all of its vibranium
because the panther god bast lets him
and then uses it to make himself god and
the only thing that can be done to stop
doctor doom is to basically take all the
vibranium and render it in earth right
to turn it into just useless pieces of
rock that stuff is cool right that's the
thing those are the kind of things that
make him interesting bouncing off people
interacting with people so let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section right do we need doctor doom in
the mcu would you want to see a
character that complex would a character
that complex work or would they have to
scale him down to a more two-dimensional
mold in order to give him uh or at least
introduce him in a way that people could
understand because if i'm being honest i
want a more dynamic three-dimensional
doctor doom that can stand the test of
time of the mcu who in some movies would
help the earth superheroes the avengers
the fantastic four the eternals and in
other stories would actively work
against them that's the kind of doctor
doom that i want to see and then
sometimes you would just sit there and
just judge them right and just be like
you guys are all incompetent and leave
that's something doctor doom would do
right that's literally something doctor
doom would do not like you okay imagine
this right you've got whoever the new
black panther is right and then you've
got like like the new avengers and
you've got like the eternals and let's
just for good measure let's say the
x-men are there right so let's say it's
the mcu ten years from now and like
there's some massive threat or something
like that right like annihilus in the
annihilation wave or coming from the
negative zone and it's going to be like
in the comics where they just they're
like a plague sweeping across the
universe and everything falls in their
path and they're all kind of sitting
around they're talking about what it is
that we should do right doctor doom like
literally dr doom would just blow the
door off right like he would just blow
the like blow the door he wouldn't even
knock he would just boom just blow the
door off they're like what's your
problem man this is how doctor doom
enters a room right so he would just he
would just walk in right and they would
they would be like okay doctor i'm like
what are your thoughts on all this and
he would just be like why would i waste
my time with you you're all incompetent
and then leave so he would literally
just show up there to tell them they're
incompetent and leave it would be
hilarious it'd be absolutely amazing but
in reality what you would know is he's
basically 10 steps ahead of him right
he's already got the problem solved they
just haven't figured it out yet and
because he's dr doom and he's just a
dick he's not going to tell him right so
it's just it's one of those things right
so let me know if that's the kind of
character you would want to see in the
marvel cinematic universe but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end uh let me know what other
villains you want us to make videos on
about who we should see in the marvel
cinematic universe because right now i
mean between like doctor doom and
annihilus it's largely been based on
like the personality types of these
characters but we could pick people like
the marquee of death or like like we
could even just go with like the
molecule man if he was just a
straight-up villain or like the beyonder
we could go with any number of those
people right who are just ridiculously
op and how none of the earth superheroes
would stand a chance because they're
just so broken let me know what you guys
think
and i will catch you all later
peace